leah how are you today i'm good how are
you doing
i'm doing fantastic it was great to meet
you last night i know you probably met a
ton of people and it was very brief but
great to meet you great to meet your
family
um
you're a superhero now
sprite can create illusions she's really
sarcastic and you're part of the marvel
cinematic universe you have some awesome
powers and i know only got so much time
so i'll just go ahead and dive right
into it love the movie that was
fantastic thought it was very powerful
now your character sprite
seems like the perfect character for you
to play
um you've mentioned in other interviews
that you kind of feel like people think
you're younger than you actually are
which is totally spray you know she's
seven thousand years old but she's stuck
in the body of a young girl um
is your character an adult in her own
mind
because she's you know been alive for
seven thousand years or has the way
other people have treated her her
family's treated her kind of
limited her thinking
to her being an adult
well
i think that she has a special
connection with her family because they
they really are the only ones who
understand the fact that she is a
really really old lady and they're the
only ones who communicate with her like
she's an adult because every other
person or human she meets in her life
looks at her as a child sure yeah so she
definitely is a very old soul and i
think she's
very smart and is frustrated because she
can't always express that
and and i think you do an incredible job
at showing that on screen and that makes
perfect sense obviously because she is
you know she's lived many many many
years and she's just attained all of
this knowledge of her time but yeah
everyone treats her the way she looks
right so that's really great to know
though that in her mind she is kind of
like a an old soul so uh you're working
with the star-studded cast on this you
know many seasoned veteran actors um did
you look to them to help you develop the
character or did you do a lot of that
work yourself
i mean it
most of it really came naturally um of
course chloe helped me out a lot with
you know really talking about it and
specific little moments that would help
develop the character and have the
audience understand her
was um really helpful
that's awesome and i know we only have
so much time left but i just wanted to
ask this movie is a huge movie and it
seems like there's a lot of really huge
developments happening with marvel
studios in the mcu spider-man knowing
home dr strange's multiverse madness it
seems like this is all kind of leading
up to something pretty big a big
crossover event um
could we possibly see you in the future
possibly joining with the avengers or
other characters down the road
well i think eternals leaves open a
bunch of possibilities which i think
is really going to excite the fans um i
have no idea what the future holds but
i'd be very excited for any of that
absolutely i hope to see you uh
many many more times down the road i
hope there's a sequel and i hope to see
you teaming up with some other people
thank you so much for your time it's
pleasure to talk to you yesterday and
today i'll see you nice to meet you
you